[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight just another evening and
is what has become a pretty high drama
country really
the jury in the kyle rittenhouse trial
has gone home for the night after many
hours of deliberations today the average
jury reaches a verdict in just a few
hours so these jurors are taking much
longer than most but it's probably not
because the evidence they have heard is
confusing them
in a typical child insider trading trial
for example something complex an honest
observer might be able to see both sides
of the case and probably can
but that is not true here far from it in
fact it's the opposite from the very
first moments of this trial it was
obvious that kyle rittenhouse never
should have been indicted in the first
place
the key question was did kyle
rittenhouse act in self-defense that
night in kenosha and the answer
unequivocally is yes obviously it's a
no-brainer like the oj trial no honest
person could reach a different
conclusion kyle written how shot men he
believed were trying to kill him now why
did kyle rittenhouse believe that you
may ask well in one case the man he shot
told him so directly i plan to kill you
of the other two men kyle rittenhouse
shot one repeatedly bashed him in the
head with a skateboard as he lay on the
ground and the other stuck a loaded gun
in his face
so kyle rittenhouse fought back in order
to save his own life
we're not guessing about that even the
prosecution's witnesses made that point
so once that happened once kyle
rittenhouse's life was threatened on the
street in kenosha what were his options
exactly well he could fight back or he
could allow himself to be murdered by
the rioters and allowing himself to be
murdered by the rioters is essentially
what the prosecution has argued he
should have done
kyle rittenhouse had a duty to submit to
the mob
well that's lunacy and no sane jury
could agree with that for a second so
the question is why is it taking so long
for this jury to produce a very obvious
verdict
want the answer we'll look outside the
courtroom
there are hundreds of national guard
troops assembled tonight in kenosha why
are they there well they've come in case
kyle rittenhouse is acquitted
not in case he's convicted in case he's
acquitted at which point if he is
acquitted pretty much everyone expects
the usual mobs of joe biden voters to
burn and loot and destroy
why does everyone expect this because
people on the left are openly calling
for it quote
now that jury deliberation has begun i
think every city in america should
prepare for what could happen if written
house gets acquitted it may get
rightfully unpleasant that's the message
from a teacher and we checked an actual
teacher from the state of indiana wrote
it on twitter today and it echoes what
many others are saying tonight
so imagine if you were a juror in this
case how would you feel about this
you're not sequestered you know how the
country feels you know what the threats
are well you might think twice before
you acquitted kyle rittenhouse no matter
what the evidence was you remember
happened after rodney king remember that
they burned los angeles to the ground
you would want to be responsible for
that you wouldn't want to spark
riots and of course that's the whole
point of the exercise
the mob threatens violence
the rest of us tremble
and pretty soon the mob controls our
justice system pretty soon the enemies
of civilization which is what they are
are in charge of the country that's
what's happening now
so it's worth pausing for a moment to
ask how do we get here exactly well
here's one summary that caught our eye
today a hill staffer called billy
gribben summed it up in the following
way quote we're waiting to see if riots
break out because of media lies about a
case from a riot that happened because
of media lies
well that's nicely put and it's totally
true
the august 2020 riot in kenosha wasn't
really a riot in the way that we
understand riots it was an outbreak of
political violence it began three days
after the democratic convention that was
the context for it it was in fact one of
many riots that summer across the
country all of which were explicitly
supported by the leadership of the
democratic party we're not making this
up look it up
what was the point of these riots well
of course big picture of the point was
to unseat donald trump
in the specific case of kenosha we know
exactly the chain of events that led to
where we are today
a man called jacob blake was shot by the
police
immediately the media and the democratic
politicians they served lied about what
happened so they told us that a
cop shot jacob blake in the back for no
apparent reason and by the way jacob
blake was unarmed he was helpless they
just pulled him out of a lineup and shot
him because that's what america is like
kamala harris then jumped in and said
she was quote proud of jacob blake like
he was a civil rights hero like he was
shot for being the wrong color as so
often happens in the systemically racist
country
but it was all totally untrue not just
the themes but the facts they were lies
in fact the police were responding to a
call from a woman who said jacob blake
was trying to kidnap her child
so the police showed up as they should
have they tried to detain jacob blake
and jacob blake fought the cops then he
grabbed a knife jacob blake was holding
that knife when he was shot by the
police jacob blake admitted that on
television
but it was too late based on the first
false stories from the news media told
intentionally
our leaders suggested that these riots
in kenosha were somehow justified and
then allowed them to continue
so this is what kenosha looked like the
night that kyle rittenhouse arrived to
help defend local businesses
[Applause]
right
well that's on the civil rights protest
that's not people fighting back against
depression systemic racism
that's just people destroying things
they didn't build that's people wrecking
our civilization in no normal country
would that be allowed it would be put
down immediately with force that's why
we have police you can't allow that
because if you do allow that people get
killed as they did
but local police you should know did
virtually nothing to stop any of the
things you just saw
from the very top of the power structure
the state of wisconsin the word was let
it happen the governor of wisconsin tony
evers in fact turned down an offer from
washington to send federal officers in
order to help get kenosha under control
to save the city
that was a shockingly irresponsible
decision it was an immoral decision
but tony ever still defends it i have no
regrets he says really that's because he
doesn't live in kenosha downtown kenosha
burned it will never be rebuilt
talk about a city that doesn't deserve
any of this kenosha is a town of just a
hundred thousand people many by the way
are hispanic if that even matters but
it's true they're not rich people who
live there kenosha is far past its prime
it was part of the industrial base that
built this country that built the modern
world
now it's suffering even more than it was
before the riots because a bunch of
entitled anti-social lunatics broke
things for no reason because our leaders
allowed them
a city official estimates the damage
from last summer's riots about 50
million dollars that's a lot in kenosha
in fact it's more than half the entire
municipal budget for the city of kenosha
so why did the people in charge allow
kenosha to be destroyed this happened
over days they allowed this
why
well for the same reason they indicted
kyle rittenhouse to send a very clear
message to the rest of us watching on
television
don't resist when the mob comes you
can't fight back we're in charge we'll
do what we want
all summer they sent that message to the
rest of us all summer they made that
very clear
here's what happened to one man who
foolishly tried to defend his own
business from looters in dallas
oh
[Applause]
there's so much video like that and at
the time we restrained ourselves and
didn't show all of it we're not going to
show all of it tonight because it's too
divisive
it's too awful it hypes people up too
much it's too emotional but it's totally
real that happened across the country to
people who did nothing wrong
so the message
over time was very very clear and again
it's the same message they're sending us
with the written house trial resistance
is futile
try to defend yourself and we're going
to throw you in jail
during closing arguments in case you
missed the point one of the prosecutors
in this case said it out loud
when the mob comes he said just let him
beat you
everybody takes the beating sometimes
right
sometimes you get in uh
a scuffle and maybe you do get hurt a
little bit
that doesn't mean you get to start
plugging people with your full metal
jacket ar-15 rounds and no bullets or
not bullets
everyone takes a beating somehow you've
taken a beating tubby i doubt it how
dare you talk like that in court
in a sane civilized society you can't
condone violence just because the people
committing it vote for the candidate you
like you can't
notice a change here though this case
has gone from white supremacist hunts
down and executes blm protesters right
like it was a racial case everyone's
white
to the new theme which is that teenager
should have accepted his beating from
the child molester arsonist was chasing
him and threatening to kill him
because he didn't he needs to go to jail
once again very clear message submit
the prosecution hammered this again and
again and again watch
why do you get to immediately just start
shooting
as mr binger said he brought a gun
to a fist fight
and he was too cowardly to use his own
fist to fight his way out
he has to start shooting
really
too cowardly a 17 year old should have
gotten in a fist fight with a 36 year
old violent pedophile
right
speaking of cowardly where were the
police who were paid to stop this stuff
who were paid to keep mob violence from
happening in the first place where's the
governor
who's under too much political pressure
to protect his own people talk about
cowardly
blaming a 17 year old who shows up
because the city his dad lives in is on
fire and he wants to do something
he shouldn't have been there in the
first place he shouldn't have had to
have been there
the adults should have been there
they're the cowards
these prosecutors are appalling this
whole spectacle is appalling
at the same time watch how the
prosecutor characterizes the pedophile's
actions the night he was shot
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage stump dumpster on
fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
that's one of the weirdest things that's
ever happened in open court that's the
prosecutor
that's a government official mocking the
idea that it's a big deal to light cars
on fire to keep the police from coming
in and restoring order it's just not a
big deal at all
that's what the prosecutor's telling us
that's what he just said
he's also saying by the way it's not a
big deal to scream
racial
slurs in public really
since when is that true this is lunacy
by the way the jury was never allowed to
hear the details
of the life of this guy joseph rosenbaum
yeah quite a history does seem sort of
relevant actually the rest of the media
is not going to tell you anything about
it so we will
in 2002 joseph rosenbaum was charged by
a grand jury with 11 counts of child
molestation including forcible sodomy
this wasn't you know
he was 19 and he had a 17 year old
girlfriend no no he raped children the
victims were five boys between the ages
of 9 and 11.
ultimately rosenbaum was sentenced to 10
years in prison for this when he got out
of prison rosenbaum destroyed his ankle
monitor the one he was required to wear
the day he died rosenbaum had an open
case for domestic abuse
they're defending this guy just hours
before he threatened to kyle kill kyle
rosen ridden house rosenbaum had been
released from mental hospital he's being
treated for some sort of disorder
obviously
he tried to go back to his fiancee but
she had a no contact order after she
pressed charges against him a month
earlier for hitting her
so this is the man they're telling you
as a model citizen
let me just remind people of the names
of the victims joseph rosenbaum who was
36 years old anthony huber who was 26.
gage gross go gross kroy who's only 27
years old was injured these are the
victims these are the people um that
people ought to remember are the people
who were hurt here not the person who
was crying on the stand today
so if if you were an honest progressive
wouldn't you ask yourself what are all
these people doing at a joe biden rally
three days after the democratic
convention they're all on my side but i
noticed that all of them are actually
horrible this is not a cross section of
america these are the worst people in
america
joseph rosenbaum the child rapist
what about the other victims well our
media tells you a main victim is a guy
called gage gross kroitz he's the guy
who ran up to kyle rittenhouse and
pointed a loaded gun in his face for
which he's never been charged by the way
that's not a big deal because he votes
the right way who is this guy well gross
kroitz it turns out also has a lengthy
criminal history that includes an arrest
for hitting his own grandmother in the
face
just six days before he testified in the
trial in fact gross kreutz was in court
on a dui charge which joe biden says is
not a big deal but most of us grew up
thinking you were not supposed to do
that
several years ago gross kreutz was
charged with smashing the bedroom window
of his ex-girlfriend's home at 4am on
the night kyle rittenhouse shot him
grosskrois has admitted he was carrying
an illegal firearm oh no longer a big
deal either gun crimes don't matter if
you vote the wrong way
sort of the last guy anthony huber he's
the man who hit kyle rittenhouse twice
in the head with a skateboard who is he
well he's a convicted domestic abuser
according to court records huber once
told his brother that if he didn't clean
a room in his house he was going to
quote gut him like a pig
huber said that while he was holding a
six inch knife to his brother's stomach
then he grabbed his brother's neck and
said this quote i'm going to burn this
house down with all of you in it
you were pleaded guilty to one count of
strangulation that time
so i guess the point is pretty simple
there are a lot of violent criminals at
this particular joe biden rally in
kenosha wisconsin last summer what are
the odds of that
kind of hard not to contrast it with
what happened on say january 6th the
insurrection they never stopped telling
us about
no one has been charged with carrying a
gun inside the capitol building that day
how many fires do they set none that
we're aware of but they get to rot in
solitary confinement anyway why gage
bruce kreutz gets the seal of approval
from msnbc anchors for appointing a
loaded gun he was carrying illegally in
the face of a child
so the kyle written house trial is
wrapping up the people who engineered
the political
prosecution behind this are still in
power
one of the main takeaways from all of
this is that those people are now more
brazen than they have ever been they're
just saying it out loud now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else